クリエイトビューが作成したファイルやフォルダについて詳しく見ていきたいと思います
まずこのbeet.config.js
これはビートの設定ファイルになります
ここにですねビューとか書いてある通り
ビートでビュー.jsを使う設定などがされていたりします
で、readme.md
これはこのプロジェクトを英語でですね
普通に説明しているだけになります
なので特になくても問題ないようなものでございます
で、次package.json
これは非常に重要なファイルになります
package.jsonっていうのは
このプロジェクト全体における
様々な設定が書かれてあるファイルになります
で、名前とかバージョンとかあるんですけれども
大事なのはこのスクリプトと
ディペンデンシーズとデブディペンデンシーズのこの3つです
で、まずディペンデンシーズとデブディペンデンシーズ
これは何なのかっていうと
ここにはこのプロジェクト内で必要な
第3者が作成したソフトウェア
そういうのをpackageと言うんですけれども
それがですね一覧で書かれています
で、viewとかbeatもpackageの1つですので
ここに書かれていますし
ESリンとかプリティアもクリエイトビューで入れる設定にしましたので
そういうのも書かれております
で、ディペンデンシーズとデブディペンデンシーズ
この2つの違う何かっていうと
デベロップメント
つまり開発の時にだけ使うパッケージは
こちらに入ります
で、本番環境
つまり実際のプロジェクトの中に入るパッケージ
実際にブラウザに渡されるパッケージですね
はこっちの普通のディペンデンシーズの方に入ります
だからviewはディペンデンシーズですし
beatとかesrintとかプリティアみたいな
開発環境でのみ使う
コードの品質を保つためのパッケージとかは
こっちのですね
デブディペンデンシーズに入るわけでございます
で、実は今ここに書かれてあるパッケージは
まだこのプロジェクトにインストールされていないんですね
あくまでもcreateviewが必要なパッケージを
このpackage.jsonの中に羅列しただけにすぎません
なのでこれをインストールする必要があるんですけれども
じゃあどうやってインストールするのかっていうと
単純にnpm installというコマンドを打ちます
そうするとですね
こんな風に自動的に
このpackage.jsonに書かれてあるパッケージが
一気にですね
インストールされます
で、インストールされたパッケージは
こちらのNodeModulesというフォルダの中に
全て入ります
このフォルダはさっきはなかったんですけれども
npm installというコマンドを打つことで
自動でですね
作られました
その上で
じゃあこのスクリプツの方は
どういう意味なのかっていうと
これはコマンドと関係していまして
npm runと書くんですね
で、その後にスペースを開けて
こちらのdevとか
buildとかpreviewとか
linterとかフォーマットを書きます
例えばdev
そうすると
このコマンドは
devの右側に書かれてあるコマンドを
入力したのと
ざっくり同じ意味になります
その上で
じゃあこのnpm run
devと押したらどうなるのかっていうと
こちらですね
このbeatコマンドが実行されて
beatが開発用のサーバーを
起動させるんですね
で、ここのURLに
ブラウザからアクセスすると
こんな風に開発中のアプリケーションを
見ることができます
で、基本的には開発中は
ずっとこのページを見ながら
開発するというのが一般的です
もしこのサーバーを
もう一度止めたい場合は
Ctrl-Cで止めることができます
追加の説明になります
収録後に
beat.config.jsに
デフォルトで
ViewDevToolsの設定が
追加されるようになったおかげで
npm rundevで立ち上げた
開発用のサーバーに
アクセスすると
こんな風にですね
下に小さいアイコンが
出るようになりました
で、ここでは
View.js専用の
開発を手助けするための
ツールを使うことができます
詳しくはまたですね
後のセクション後の
コンポーネントのところで
紹介します
とりあえずですね
こういうのが出ていますが
特にですね
講座の内容に影響はありませんので
ご安心ください
ちなみにですけれども
こっちの下の方のURLを開くと
As a Separate Window
別のですね
ウィンドウとして
そのDevToolsを
開いてくれるようになりますので
ここにアクセスすると
こんな風にですね
今のDevToolsが
画面一杯に
別のタブとして
表示されるようにも
なったりします
し
こっちのですね
キーボードショートカットキーを
入力すると
Toggle the ViewDevTools
ということで
そのですね
ツールを
トグルすることができます
なのでこの状態で
先ほどの
キーボードショートカットキーを
入力すると
こんな風にですね
開いたり閉じたり
することができたりもします
それでは
講座の続きをどうぞ
NPM Learn Buildと
入力したらどうなるのかというと
この
Beat Buildコマンドが
実行されるんですけども
これは何なのかというと
開発が全て終わって
実際にリリースするとなった時に
初めて使用するコマンドになりまして
こんな風にですね
入力すると
Beatが
Dist Folderというフォルダを
こんな風に作ってくれるんですね
で
このDist Folderは
公開するためのもので
コードがですね
こんな風にすごく
最適化されたりします
でこのDist Folderを
アプリを公開してくれるようなサービス
そういうのを
静的ホスティングサービスとか
言ったりするんですけども
そういうところに
このDist Folderを
渡すことで
あなたのアプリを
世界中に
リリースすることができます
まあ
ここら辺のですね
詳細のやり方に関しては
また講座の最後で
紹介したいと思います
で
NPM Learn
プレビュー
これはですね
非常にシンプルで
この
ビルドで作ったDist Folderが
正しく動いているかどうかを
確かめるものになります
だから
このように
NPM Learn
プレビューと
すると
サーバーが立ち上がるんですけれども
今回のこのサーバーは
この
Dist Folderの中身を
シンプルに
レスポンスとして
返すサーバーになっています
だから
このURLを開いて
見てみることで
あ
ちゃんとですね
本番のDist Folderの中身も
開発の時と
同じように動いているんだなと
こういうことをですね
確かめることができます
でもこれもですね
Ctrl Cで止めることができます
次
NPM Learn
Lintですね
これは
CreateViewの時に
ESLintを入れたので
追加されたんですけれども
NPM Learn
Lintというコマンドを
このように
入力することで
コードがですね
正しく書けているか
というのをチェックして
修正してくれたりします
今は特にですね
変なコードはないので
エラーは出ません
ちなみに最新の
パッケージ.jsonでは
Lintコロン
OXLintで
OXLintだけでチェックして
Lintコロン
ESLintで
OXLintが対応していない
ESLintだけが
対応できる部分をチェック
普通のLintコマンドで
この両方を実行する
という風になっています
なので普通に
このLintコマンドを
使うことで
コード全体をチェックして
エラーを見つけることができます
でNPMLANフォーマットですね
こんな風に
NPMLANフォーマット
とすると
Prettyerが
綺麗にフォーマットしてくれます
ただ現状これも
ESLintと同じで
最初のコードが
すでにフォーマットされた
綺麗な状態ですので
今回は特に
修正されたりはしません
じゃあ次
package-lock.jsonですね
これは
NPMインストールの
コマンドを打った時に
インストールされた
このロードモジュールズの中にある
パッケージの
厳密なバージョンが
一覧でですね
記録されている
みたいなものになります
これはですね
そこまで重要ではありません
さあここで
追加情報なんですけれども
収録後に
js.config.jsonというファイルが
最初に存在するファイルとして
追加されました
これは
Visual Studio Codeが
効率よく
コードを管理するために
必要な設定ファイルになりまして
特にですね
普段意識する必要はありません
さらにですね
.editor.configというファイルも
追加されました
こちらはですね
vs.codeだけじゃなくて
様々なエディタに対して
一貫したコーディングスタイルの
ルールを
そのエディタに適用させるための
ファイルになります
なので例えば
タブを押した時の
インデントのサイズ
とかですね
こういうファイルが追加されました
またですね
こちらが
eslintの設定ファイルになるんですけれども
こちらもですね
もともとは
.eslintrc.cjsという
名前のファイルだったんですけれども
最新のバージョンでは
eslint.config.jsという
ファイルに変わりました
中身もですね
かなり違う書き方になっています
こちらのeslintの設定や
editor.configに関しては
次のレクチャーでも
もう一度説明いたします
それでは講座の続きをどうぞ
で
index.html
これはこのプロジェクト全体の
webアプリケーションの
元になる
htmlのファイルになります
で
beetは
このrootフォルダの直下にある
index.htmlを
開発用のサーバーに
アクセスしたときは
返していますし
このdistフォルダの中にある
index.htmlも
このindex.htmlを
元にして作られています
ただこっちの方が
最適化されていますので
例えばですけれども
このスクリプトタグとかも
本番用のdistフォルダの中の
htmlでは消えて
こっちのですね
ヘッドタグの方に移動していたりします
で
pretierrc.json
これはpretierの設定ファイルになります
で
git.ignore
これはgitの設定
で
esintrc.cjs
これはesintrc.json
ここが一番メインとなる
開発者が最も頻繁に使用する部分になります
基本的にですね
.viewファイルとか
JavaScriptとかcssは
全てこのソースフォルダの中に置くようになっています
ちなみにbeetは内部的にですね
このソースフォルダの中にあるファイルに対しては
様々な変換の処理を行っています
それは例えばviewのファイルをJavaScriptに変換する処理とか
他にも公開する時とかに最適化の処理を行うとか
で
こういうですね
いろんな処理っていうものは
基本的にはbeetがうまくやってくれているので
すごくいいんですけれども
例えばもしbeetに何も操作されたくないようなファイルを作りたい場合
この時どうしたらいいのかっていうと
そういう時に使用するのが
このソースフォルダの一つ上にある
パブリックフォルダというものになります
beetはこのパブリックフォルダの中にあるファイルだけは
一切何も手を加えずに
そのまま
例えばディストフォルダの中だったら
そのディストフォルダの直下に
今はファビコンと対しようというファイルがあるんですけども
それをですね
そのまま置いてくれます
開発用のサーバーの場合は
ちょっともう一度開発用のサーバーを立てるんですけれども
URLの後に
スラッシュで
そのファイルの名前
fabicon.icoという風に打ち込むことで
そのファイルを取得できたりします
このですね
パブリックフォルダに関しましては
開発中というよりかは
アプリをリリースするタイミングとかで
使用することが多いですので
今はですね
こういうものがあるんだ
程度にですね
思っていただければなと思います
で最後
.vscodeフォルダ
こちらは
vscodeの設定をするためのフォルダになります
こちらですね
少し長くなりますので
次のレクチャーで詳しく紹介したいと思います
フォルダに関しましては